good afternoon
thank you for taking time to join us in
this webinar
designing for the future burger king
restaurant
my name is jewell and i am from the
design singapore council
i will be your event emcee and moderator
for today
a session today is brought to you by
design singapore council
and is supported by burger king
singapore
and national design center this webinar
is part of series of engagement and
sharing sessions
under the good design research
initiative which aims to help designers
and design enterprises in singapore
find the unique value proposition in
designing for impact
through research and experimentation and
a network of knowledge partners
now please allow me to introduce the
speakers and this afternoon's program
my colleague hoyme from design singapore
council
will be joining us shortly to share an
overview of the good design
research initiative next we will have mr
goh chin hao
ceo of bear king singapore and
restaurant designer mr faison zedek
to share with us about burger king's
future online
offline hybrid dining experiences that
they seek
to engage designers in burger king
singapore
operates more than 50 outlets in
singapore today
after first arriving in singapore in
1982
finally we will end the session with a q
a segment
as well as the timeline for the upcoming
gdr events
including the next gdr open call where
you could submit
an application if you are keen to
respond
to burger king's challenge statement
without further ado
we will start the session with an
introduction to the good design
research initiative well may please
thanks jewell for the quick introduction
and thank you all for taking the time to
join us today
so i'm not sure how many of you would
have heard about the good design
research initiative
and so i'd like to take this opportunity
to share with you a little bit more
about the background
so first i'll be sharing on why good
design research
is important and then secondly on the
key elements of this initiative
its importance in today's context was
very apparent when we conducted our
research in close consultation with
designers
and design enterprises we interviewed
over 40 of them
with most of them recognizing that
designing for impact
which is also what most will recognize
as good design
will help them shape their value
proposition and stand out in the global
marketplace
and on the demand side there has always
been a recognition
of the role that design can play in
mitigating the world's complex
issues this is especially apparent in
the covet pandemic
and the design innovation that we need
right now goes beyond simply
improving the user experiences for
retail but that also requires deep
research
clearly there is a need for deep
research that is fundamental to good
design
however good design research requires
two key things right we
require significant investment as well
as a strong network that is not always
possible with smaller design firms
and therefore we're the good design
research initiative the design council
plans to bridge these two resource gaps
for our designers
the first part of the good design
research initiative aims to build a
strong network
to foster multidisciplinary
collaborations that are necessary for
design
impact projects we are hoping to achieve
these
through this webinar as well as the
subsequent sharing and engagement
sessions
through inviting impact-driven speakers
with challenge statements
that you may respond to or even experts
in the fields of technology
systems and processes or identity and
culture with concepts or tools that you
may leverage on for your projects
the second part of the good design
research initiative aims to support
exploratory
projects through open calls for example
if you are keen to respond to
burger king's challenge statement that
they will be sharing later on
you may submit a proposal for the open
call
coming up in march next year and
potentially receive
sponsorship mentorship as well as
publicity support
through these two key phases the good
design research encourages designers to
develop
unique value proposition it seeks to
support designers embarking on projects
with deep explorations and research into
these
three key tracks that you see on the
left here identity and culture
systems and processes as well as new
technologies
it also seeks to support designers who
embarking on projects with a focus on
design
impact and with this i hope that you
that you have a good
overview of what the good design
research initiative is all about
at the end of the session we will also
have a qr code where you can find out
more information about the initiative
and with this i will pass the time back
to joule
thank you humay so for today's session
we
are actually going to give a bit more
time to qna because i do understand
quite a few of us
have quite a lot of key questions good
questions
for their guest speakers today as well
so
we will now like to invite mr goh chin
hao ceo of burger king singapore
to share with you about burger king
singapore's future dining experiences
the seat designers for mr go please hey
everybody
how are you guys doing i'm looking for a
window and i think it's uh singapore is
having a thunderstorm right now
uh a great time a great time to talk
about uh the challenge statement today
very appropriate especially when uh just
before this session i order home degree
and you you you should know that uh when
it rains cats and dogs right delivery
will always be delayed why am i saying
that the delivery part is um
is going to be part of the conversation
i think i think for the start uh
the later we know that uh the covet has
done a lot of um
has actually enabled a lot of changes
okay some behavioral
uh some digital and burglary itself has
to
pivot towards the future i think the
topic today
we want to take on is really what
happens in the new norm
and what is the future burger king looks
like in the future
okay so but before i go into that i'd
like to introduce myself first um
it's my graduate week here my name is uh
go ching hao
i'm the ceo for king singapore okay
and uh i have i'm very happy to also
have my colleague feisin here
he's uh he's our restaurant manager uh
designer
and i will start with uh introduction
and i'll talk a bit about
the challenge statement and the context
of it after that i'll hand over to fizzy
where he will walk us through the
current existing design framework that
we are currently
utilizing okay first and foremost
thank you psg for organizing this
important session
uh we are very excited about this
partnership okay and really look forward
to having many many outcomes
uh from the challenge statement we have
posted okay because personally i believe
that uh design is
can be a game changer okay and it's
actually a very powerful tool
uh for business growth okay so
um and and i really hope that uh we
defined
the question enough and sufficiently and
we take time to answer your questions as
well
for us to be able to look forward to
some exciting proposals from you guys
okay a little bit about burger king so
burgey arrived in singapore in 1982
okay and the first straw uh you it was
actually in peninsular plaza
okay right now uh of course on one
humble outlet
we have seen grown our trend strength we
are now at 56 stores
okay the most recent store we opened was
in churchukam
okay we did the community center
okay so working itself what are we
famous for
we are famous for our whopper sandwiches
okay so
and more importantly uh we own flame
grill
so flame growing which means using real
fire
to cook our patty our product patties
okay
and we are also famous for our rendang
burger and also
our double mushroom swiss okay this
these are the products that actually
resonated
with the singaporean culture uh so just
to before i go into a chinese statement
i want to take some time to show you
guys about
uh two different designs that we
currently have
within the singapore banking portfolio
so one of them
about uh it was actually the one and
only
what we call the bk prime concept um
and it is actually in uh we use it to
open together which
were uh in chiang mir and changi airport
uh in april 2019
this style is very transformative it's
because uh we decided to adopt a design
okay that is more edgy and forward
especially using
the uh using a lot of our existing brand
icons such as you can see on the bottom
left picture
you will see a big burger king logo uh
being
blown up and actually uh pasted on the
wall
okay and now on the right side you will
see
our famous water stripes these these are
the colors
uh that we use and you can also look at
it so far
we actually apply it across the
furniture as well i'm creating a
consistent look
okay we know that this design actually
works well uh it also
it also help us to reach out to the
millennials and
the gen z because it's vastly different
from what we have
in the rest of the stores
the next design uh it's actually a store
uh you'll see photos from this store
it's actually to celebrate our 50th
store
in singapore okay and that was opened in
july 2019
okay this design is atypical of many
bulking
stores that you see around the island
okay and likewise
this is more or less the staple design
that we use across the globe as well
okay so this design has been actually
with us for maybe
five to ten years okay but the prime
design that you saw earlier
was something that uh we decided to
launch uh once we got the blessing from
our main franchisor uh burger king
global
okay so this design is uh you can see
it it tries to create the view of a
barbecue
okay uh natural authenticity in in the
design elements and the brick wall
and the heritage wall the photos that
you see at the back on the bottom left
picture
okay and we usually adorn the the layout
itself the dining area with juicy
pictures of our burgers okay
so i think a bit of the contacts are to
the challenge statement
okay before i go into it i think kovit
has really
dealt a big blow to a lot of businesses
in singapore
specifically i'm talking about uh fast
food so i think
uh if you guys have been around since
april you would have known
uh the situation it wasn't really
looking positive and but we still need
to feed the nation
this is that is what we see our position
as and fast food
with our food safety product and our
ability to ramp up
uh is probably one of the best partners
that we can work with the
government to develop a different dining
experience
okay so and it is also a time that we
see
um adoption acceleration
uh in is accelerating adoption of
technology
so we already have an existing mobile
app and we already have the
self-ordering jobs
okay and we also be working with the
home
delivery partners like food panda grab
and uh
and uh deliver room uh all these times
okay but what we saw in the month of
april and may
okay when one of our competitors is
affected by
it we saw our sales really went up
significantly
okay and and really means it is really
very
important but however uh what we also
experience is the impatience
okay and also that the existing design
of the restaurant
is not conducive for such a massive crop
trying to get into burger king to order
food okay so we experienced a lot of uh
downtime as well including customers who
are very upset with us
uh especially during the part that it
becomes if
they have to literally wait 35 minutes
to 45 minutes
for their meal some even up to two hours
okay especially when we are flooded with
the three orders
so that that was the context of uh when
we met up with psg
we were talking about it and then we
were talking about how does
how does the future looks for us you
know is my existing
current restaurant design uh really
adapted
for the new norm or was it that we could
have
we we actually just managed to make do
and and pull through this
crisis you know but firmly deep down i
believe that this is here to stay
you know and and having sanitizers are
dispensing
are being placed in my outlets it's no
longer an exception
okay it's become the norm okay likewise
we are also
just to give some examples exploring
like contactless door that you can
actually have auto door opening
or we can have actually have the sink
for example for people to wash their
hands
okay and what i'm trying to say is that
he has actually redefined
the whole dining experience in the past
we have a very picky cutter kind of
layout for
the restaurant you know we basically cut
the restaurant into two thirds i wanted
wanted for the kitchen
and the service counter and then after
that the rest of it
i will be the front of house which is
where the dining dining experience is
concentrated
and we used a lot of existing furnitures
and so far and
high table seats uh to define the
different
uh segment the seats uh segment the
dining area to cater to the different
needs of our customers
okay and likewise the kills itself so
the kills itself as
and we even uh we have to make sure that
the sanitation
process on the chaos is done at least
hourly okay to
to give customers the assurance that we
are very
we are focusing on uh utmost priority on
uh safety as well so these are some
examples
of uh the context of how where where
what we are doing today
okay and why we have arrived at the two
challenge statement that you saw on the
screen today
okay so the first one is how might we
design future fast food restaurants
uh that enhances guest experiences
amidst the current
uh challenges that we're facing such as
a social dismissal policy
okay and uh is this a new not moving
forward
okay an example would be during those
days uh we need to
do we need to survive uh burger king
need to do business
so but we cannot afford to cut back on
the number of seats
okay a lot of our previous business
model
is actually based on sig cal and
tableton's
uh very typical of many restaurants that
you saw outside
so how when when when we have to start
maintaining one meter apart
and when we review the layout okay when
flights didn't have to
uh review 56 stores often like
the sitting plan you can imagine the
stress for operations as well
and to ensure that we have to have the
table separated at least one meter apart
you know then there was a time that uh
we decided to
also look into other other countries and
other market
and we saw that some other markets
creatively came up with what they call
the table separator
so this is actually a very large size
acrylic
poster or acrylic piece that
creates a physical barrier between one
table
one table of guests to the next table
and and honestly to us that was uh we
thought that was the perfect solution
okay however the interpretation is very
different
uh let me share with you we have
different stores and we have the rich
ships what they call the safety
sentencing ambassadors
uh they have very different
understanding okay that's what we
realize
as well okay to them uh the one meter
still
still is not allowed even though you
have a physical barrier
yes you may be uh curious how this is
but the truth is
uh there is no really no proper
guidelines okay
so we were left to our own what i'm
trying to say is that we left our own to
try to develop solutions
that work okay and many times we relate
back to the government
okay uh mom moh okay
to talk to them and explore like what is
what it is and
and try to impress upon them that hey
you know being
and being a conglomerate
we have the ability to feed people we
have the ability to scale up
and we can help to re-write the future
the fmp industry okay so that is part of
the context why
we decided decidable dsg to establish
so-called the new norm okay but our
ideas are always limited so we wanted to
tap into a larger design
community and and take this chance you
know
and us being a very willing partner hope
to get some
uh spark off some proposals and
which may be highly relevant to uh to us
instead of uh just having a current stop
gap
solution okay and along the way
as we are we we also realize another
problem we face is when we're doing a
lot of digitalization
the adoption rate is increasing okay we
used to only have about 20
of the downloads and they were active
users okay now we
see as high as 40 okay and and however
we also realized that uh uh we neglected
the true human connection
you know my auntie who used to work at
the counter
are doing uh doing counter service
taking orders
uh also because of their we were worried
about their health because of the
application of profit you know they may
be more vulnerable
so we also decided that uh perhaps they
probably shouldn't be customer-facing
but then we also have customers coming
to the store telling us that hey you
know we crave the human connection that
auntie offers me
and the familiarity that every morning i
walk in
uh the auntie will immediately just uh
key
my order you know i don't really like
the cures i don't
you know as much as i know that you have
such things but
we try not to use it the reason is
because we pray for human connections
okay so i'm sharing with you real
anecdotes
uh from our customers who actually
actively do
write to us through facebook give us
feedback okay
digitalization did enable us to connect
a lot more easy
and actually allow us to move into a lot
of
cashless procedures as well which you
which largely is actually beneficial for
the business moving ahead
you know as we don't have to tell money
and things are more in line
data are more stream uh faster into the
cloud and we can
see the information faster but yet the
the
authenticity of human connections uh is
is also being told to us that is missing
you know
some of them have even joked that
perhaps then in that case
uh perhaps why don't we don't even need
to have a counter
for the for to face the customers we
just have to
we just need to have pigeon holes for
example uh to place the or their order
in the pigeon hole and allow them to uh
open it uh and with the with the pin
sent to their mobile phone you know
and i'll be honest with you this is what
we have we are
looking into okay but uh i decided that
this may not be what the customers
really want
okay and which is why today we decided
to come up with a challenge statement
okay so let's let me just read out the
two challenge statement again
okay uh the first one is how might we
design future fast food restaurants that
enhances
guest experiences amidst the current
challenges we are facing
okay and then the other one is how are
we designed to establish
authentic human connections when
integrating digital elements
in this new experiences
okay for taught okay thanks
so what are we looking for okay we're
looking for ideas
okay uh online offline hybrid
uh ideas you know basically to uh
experiences
for the future fast food restaurant for
our future burger king restaurant
okay including designs and concepts
okay contactless restaurant service okay
uh right now we already have it but i'd
love to hear from
you guys experts and see what what way
we can actually humanize the contactless
process okay and then uh also
taking into consideration interior and
exterior facade of a drive-through
and dining experience okay
our workflow back and also the workflow
itself the back of house workflow
and front of house operations we're
listing all this down
is because we don't want to limit to
only one section
of the restaurants okay we're looking
for proposals
uh literally for the whole restaurant
for the whole business
okay which is why you can see the
channels that we're focusing
on uh even inclusive driver and dining
okay one of the reason why we are doing
this is actually building support
apparently does not have heavy
drive through okay but uh
we decided that uh if this works out we
already have a side year mark for
drive-through
but that is in 2022 so we think that is
the perfect timing
uh if we do get amazing fantastic
proposals
uh we may actually work out some
commercial arrangement
to have it applied to the the
drive-through style we're opening in
2022
okay the subjects of the challenge in
this case
would involve creative space planning uh
the reason why this is to define the
operation flow the kitchen
especially okay and and to allow for the
customer journey
and where the activity should be held
okay
uh reason for this is as you can see
when
we have the search we have some stores
that was never really designed for home
delivery
however because of covet we saw the huge
search in home debris orders
and uh at any particular moment uh
you shouldn't be surprised to see more
than 20 delivery writers
waiting for their orders okay so what
happens
because if you have a store that already
have 50 seats being taken out because of
social business managers
but yet you need to create sufficient
space to hold
home delivery partners where they come
and collect their food
so this is what we're talking about we
need help with the creative space
planning
and how do we ensure the safe movement
for the people when they're in the
restaurant as well okay
it is also not limited we can also talk
about the proposals can also be
talking about ordering and payment
systems okay and the various methods
uh that uh that are forward looking how
do we go about adopting them
here the channels itself as i mentioned
would include pickup dining to go
drive-through and also particularly
third party support
hope delivery services okay
you can talk about digitalization
interactive
okay we all we we talked about ai as
well
okay and and at the end of it we also
still want to ensure that the restaurant
is not too clinical
so we appreciate some ideas and
proposals for the dining space aesthetic
and the function
okay and and greenery are definitely
welcome
we do have some stores that for example
you work with amps
that we actually design a garden
a garden wall i think fizzing can shed
more light on that data
okay so this is some of the subjects are
the
you can see that it's all-encompassing
okay and we are also omni-channel
okay but how do we redefine a brick and
mortar
store like a drive-through store that we
are going to open in 2022
how do we uh redesign that to ensure
that
we enhances human connection despite
digitalization
yeah okay and we still can continue to
offer
uh good food and in a more safe
environment to our customers
okay so next i will uh is actually a
floor plan
okay uh that we we decided that
it's necessary to give everybody a space
to work with
okay uh and this is this is the floor
plan you're looking at now
okay uh this is as real as it is like
guys okay you will see the floor track
and and uh even the specific information
will be included inside
okay so um before i take on any
questions
uh i'm going to hand over to faison okay
if i zip will
walk us through will walk us through the
existing design framework that we have
been designing for working
in singapore okay over geophysics
hi okay hi guys uh hope you're all doing
well
i am fuzzy from burgundy singapore and
we design a restaurant from
berlin singapore okay uh generally
i would like to talk about back later on
the next slide
to show you the brand concept three
brand concept of burger king
global okay uh before i started off uh
the flow plan that i show you in the
screen right now the slide is actually a
generic
uh typical uh normal layout so
it is not really related to any uh
restaurant or something like that
it's basically a space for you to work
on so at least everybody have a fair
share of
space to go on rather than the provo
came back with all different kind of
layouting and there so at least to be
fair everybody have to be
challenging is to create a space the
flow
and actually define the space of boh and
the foh
okay the next slide i want to show you
is actually the brand concept
okay we have three brand concept uh
firstly is a garden grill
say garden grill is one of the pioneer
concepts which
actually been still been using in global
uh burger king around the world okay you
these are all the reference uh reference
of the brand concept
you have to take note about the warm and
natural color based on the concept
you have a banquet wall sitting these
are all the zones uh
garden walls sitting both sitting the
counter how you look like
and loose dining and sittings
so you please think about these are just
a reference okay you not necessarily
have to be injected into your proposal
but just take note that
the color have to be warm and natural
okay for the yo it's open to ideas no
doesn't mean
it will be though blanket wall to be in
the straight form you can have a curve
s-shape or whatever you like depending
on your proposal
uh it take now on the ceiling so these
are the key elements that you just
take note on the designing for working
in totality okay the next one is
actually a prime
prime is more edgy more colorful more uh
heat in terms of sitting
a bit off a bit of edgy but somehow
other
infusing some colors to create some hype
executive is warm natural and bold
please take note that this is just a
reference again
okay it's actually banking wall
the crown wall booth sitting the counter
and also the loose seating and dining
you can see that the
communal table is different from the
rest and the floor finishes
biscuits all these are all referenced to
the color of the concept
you may have some proposal you have
maybe some function that you need to
integrate
the the table uh some device in it
by all means these are all just a
reference to to have it infused to all
the technology in our furniture itself
you can modify here and there but take
note on the color itself
and the last one is royal which is
currently the
current nozzle current but actually the
new concept of working which moving
forward
most of our global will be having this
type of concept
same thing the color theme is actually
warm in nature
with vibrant essence as you can see that
the furniture is slightly different it's
a little bit more 60s but
it's a bit more on the nostalgia side
but infuses color to make it more modern
if it were light wood tone and the
ceiling the feature ceiling is there
the communal table is also slightly
different even the bus tool sitting is
more
industrial and aging modern modern
settings
so you can see that the color is very
warm very natural
and a touch of like splash of green
orange
yellow to make it more hyped to make the
store looks modern okay these are the
three concepts
for your for you to have an idea and a
reference how our working global brand
uh look like okay not necessarily you
have to follow the same we just like to
make it more
ideal to give you an idea how the
brand's concept is
okay before i proceed i would like to
elaborate more on the
the key subject of the challenge okay
like my ceo was previously was saying
that
okay the creative space planning we are
looking at is something that you
you need to define the boh and foh the
boh is where
the back of house where this is the
money making bay
where we create a service and and create
the food we cook the food everything we
grill the burger and we serve it this is
the place where we need to be like a
serving area
we need to make sure that how this the
challenge is how
we deliver the food and serve the food
to the customer in the counter or maybe
counterless
or maybe just like a board a pigeon hole
like my ceo saying
but having a generic pigeon hole maybe
some interactive in the pigeon hole
saying that your food is ready
in a few minutes and there is some
graphic so make it more alive this is
part of the human
touch that maybe we're looking at some
general reference
and like ordering payment system maybe
you're looking at some
ideas of digital touch screen or
holographic
our crew standing there in front
holographically then after that they
were saying that hi welcome to burger
king i mean
we take our order so it's virtual so it
is some of the ideas that
are also looking at for the working
future uh
not necessarily as a ordering kiosk or
maybe can have a
uh what they call it voice services like
a bank start a bank retail they are
using voice services
so these still have a human touch
connection
and for the defined space aesthetic and
function
uh basically you have ideas of having a
digitalization is a device by itself but
how to integrate this device
into our concept maybe it's like a box
up with some elements
uh infuse it inside out in one of our
tables
or sitting when ordering from the table
i mean it's contactless
to our crew but apparently uh what we
have right now
is actually basically all the ordering
chaos is by standalone
so what we need an idea on this is a
reference of either how we can go about
into utilization infused into the
functional aesthetic
okay then the last thing is on the green
aesthetic okay this green aesthetic is
actually
an idea some some idea to input some
uh what i call it greenery in a in a
restaurant basically with all
digitalization
interactive touchscreen wireless wi-fi
5g 6g
everything all these are include
radiation
so having a generally aesthetic actually
reduce and absorb
radiation so we we can think along the
way some science
uh ideas to induce uh to make it
safe for all our customers and also our
crew
then the uh what like like i want to say
you bet the creative space planning to
define our operation and flow
you can have a you can have a two
separate
uh zone whereby you can't see the crew
by
the food is still delivered and humans
touch like in touch of the voice
recording a voice services or some
digital panel or some interactive panel
that you can talk to our crew if there's
any
doubt or problems when receiving the
order same goes to the drive-through
these are all the challenges and the
function that we are looking at
when you have a drive-through the moment
you drive
you order you pay and you collect but
this is all contactless
so this is how we need to which is how
the challenge that we need to
get it perfectly done and make sure that
it's
the theme of contactless restaurant
service because right now you still
you still make a payment through a
counter if you do
like like a mcdonald drive-through you
still make payment physically make
payment
at the window and physically collect so
we try to eliminate that
contactless how can we have a space or
zone
where a driver can pick up the food by
itself
so in the whole totality concept we
bring this concept
into our restaurant where you are
literally
physically not driving but actually
we're just walking to our
restaurant making order payment and
collect
and also you need to make sure that the
social distancing
that we are having right now and you
might be going
moving forward uh years to come maybe
you need to define a space of
dine-in the collection of the delivery
guys and also the collection of the
pickup
where people go there and just pick up
and go to go
so these are all the challenges and some
of the ideas that you might need to
think of
and infuse inside the challenge concept
so other than that i would like you
[Music]
to paint over to jewel and good luck and
we hope to see your nice
and wonderful proposal to work on with
thank you
thank you faizan thank you mr goh chin
hao and
for bringing us through that insightful
presentation
if you have any queries about them in
the presentation
please submit them through the zoom q a
module so that we may address them
during this q a segment so we're now
moving into this
um q a segment right here and there are
some questions coming through already
through the chat
and you have any other thoughts from the
sharing please feel free to keep them
coming we may not have the full time to
address them right here but
we will still follow up with your
questions as well
so we do actually have a first question
right here
what is the current customer mix in
general
does a bug can attract more families
kids
white collars or students young adults
would you like to maybe have a breakdown
okay uh let me address this question
okay berkeley itself our target audience
is actually the pmeds
and actually uh more of the savvy uh
people who know how to enjoy life better
so that is actually uh our our profile
for customers
uh they appreciate the final final
things food in life
so families yes okay we do have families
but our proportion is probably only
about 20
uh 40 to 60 percent actually is 1 pm in
bees
yeah and we've got another question
coming in so
um the brief actually asks about a
contactless restaurant service
and authentic human connections which
seem contradictory so if burger king
could maybe explain
what sort of human connections are
envisioned without this physical
human contact okay actually i think
feizen did
uh gave some examples for example the
holographic
uh vr and things like that uh so this is
this as much as a contradiction uh but
we feel that that is the crux of the
issue we are facing now
okay many times people believe that i
thought that contactless means that
uh there is really no human touch to it
i think that that actually goes back to
our chinese statement we hope to find a
proposal within practice
okay um and
the next question so what are actually
the expectations of this proposal are
there
would you be expecting visualizations
prototypes maybe you can elaborate on
that a little bit
okay the the main main focus of this uh
challenge is the concept you can have a
visualization you can have a
3d visual kind of mockup but it's all
depend is just the initial stage
the the main priority is how you define
this concept
and the challenge to suit our needs like
like like
the contactless how do you do the
contactors you don't need to be a
totally
uh 3d visual but it will be good to have
some visualizers to at least we know
what are the concept being addressed to
us like for
that that's why the whole thing that i
give you the whole plan it's just a
simple plan
from the plan itself it can turn out to
be into a
concept by zoning not necessary to be
physically
draw everything by the reference of the
brain concept which i already shared
earlier
to infusing into your zone maybe some
sitting zone
uh what you call it so far area banking
area and then then after that you infuse
into your technology that you're
proposing
so not necessary to be uh 3d visual but
it's all depend on your presentation
so that the ideas that cross over to us
is
fine i mean we don't know what you try
this is the concept
and so
one other question has come in it's um
are there any architectural
elevation drawings for the proposed site
uh currently we don't have it like i
said there is just a general
uh what they call it layouts so we want
to
make sure that the concept is right
before it put it into the real
actual layout i mean in terms of uh
the proposal will be slightly a bit
different to the actual site
but at least the concept is there the
concept is is along
along the way no matter how the layout
is
at least the concept is can be in can be
used and implemented to any of the
layout
that will be available in singapore for
bulking
a restaurant okay and
um the next question here actually how
was the the prior design process like um
did you work with external designers or
were things done in the house
or were there areas in the previous
design process you felt were lacking
okay uh we uh actually we have our own
designers
so i mean one of them um i want the
teams
so basically we have to follow protocol
based on a
global concept here and a global concept
so we have also have a priority
to have our own ideas which we will
share to global that they get
this concept will suit to this
environmental area
let's say like for instance the end park
project we need to create some garden
wall which is not
in the uh 100 global concept idea
but after when we infuse it this they're
actually think about it yeah because
these are all the current
uh in environmental area that we need to
put in
so these are all the the ideas that we
can have it
uh to infuse it's not about lacking of
ideas it's just that
we have to straight protocol based on
the global because we it's a brand
standing we need to make it
all over the uh global same uh brand
standard
at least to cover 90 or 80
of it okay okay yeah that was another
question that came in quite similar in
that area of
um take what would the proposal have to
take into the consideration of the
operations in other parts of the world
so um maybe if you like to add a bit
more to that in specific areas or
will you say that that has your answers
fully covered this question for the
for the uh the person
okay i can answer this uh no right now
is not
however if it's commercially adopted
with a bit with the
global blessing it may become a global
project
so there is a chance for international
collaboration
yes yes we have seen other markets uh
in europe uh best become best practices
and actually share
among the network okay
and um what are the the main
deliverables for proposals
that's another question has come through
okay the main deliverable is actually
uh how we define the current containers
restaurant design i mean apart from from
seeing all this
social distancing the divided skin and
everything
we also wanted to have some ideas like
fully automated
uh restaurant whereby you just enter the
restaurant
without any uh crew or the crew we
backpack or house it's just like you
just
order paid and pick up so the lacking
part of it is the human touch
so this is where the challenge that we
know how to integrate the human touch
into our digitalization right now as per
my ceo was
addressed earlier where people complain
that
they are they never get a welcome uh
no so welcome uh invite welcome uh
from our counter crews say that welcome
to working
there's no more of that already because
a lot of them will be oh please proceed
to the
please proceed to the ordering kiosk uh
fees proceed to the ordering curve
so to someone not a tech savvy or maybe
the old people
they may might be some trouble to having
ordering the food
so they prefer the traditional way
walking through the counter order with
and cup
let me see okay and we're actually
quickly approaching the end of this
q a session right here so one last
question that
that is here it's actually if the sky is
the limit
what would the burger king restaurant
the future look like
i i probably wouldn't be able to
describe uh
the appearance of a restaurant but i
would say that it is a restaurant that
actually will be able to fulfill the
experiences of
an expectation of all our customers
coming to the store
okay with our basic good food and food
safe
okay well um thank you very much
panelists
for this engaging conversation for those
of you who are
keen on design impact projects and are
seeking for inspiration
and suitable project partners we hope
that this webinar has inspired you
and to design for the future we are keen
to explore design research projects
in this area are keen to respond to
burger king singapore's challenge
statement
please reach out to us or burger king
for more information
and we also would love to have you
participate
in our next gdr open call in march 2021
so my colleague huayme will be sharing
more about our next
gdr open call who am i please
hi thanks joel so uh if you are keen to
learn more about the gdr challenge
statements do look out for
upcoming gdr sharing and engagement
session happening in mid-january
you may also scan the qr code on the
bottom left
where we will also have other existing
challenge statements that you can
respond to
so as joel has mentioned earlier on if
you are keen to respond to the burger
king singapore's challenge statements or
actually any other challenge statements
listed on our website do participate in
our next gdr open call happening in
march 2021
to stand a chance to receive cash
sponsorship mentorship
and publicity support for your proposal
so before we end the session we would
like to do a quick poll to have a sense
on how many of you and the audience
would like to submit
a proposal addressing butler king's
challenge statement in the next gdr open
call okay
so the poll results are in and almost 80
percent of you would like to submit a
proposal responding to the challenge
statements
we look forward to your submissions in
the next gdr open call in march
we also look forward to you attending
more of our events
upcoming events yep and with this i'll
pass the time back to jewel
yeah thank you hoyme so um we hope you
found this session inspiring and
meaningful
once again we would like to thank you
for joining us this afternoon
and our speakers for the inspiring
insightful sharing
as a follow-up to the webinar we will be
actually sharing a summary of the
session along with the contact details
for our speakers after the session so
you may scan the qr code
for more details on the good design
research initiative
as well as the challenge statements
including those from our knowledge
partners like
burger king singapore and open challenge
statements as well you'll find them on
the website
so we hope to see you at subsequent
events or
even your submissions under the open
call
so thank you and see you soon